[Musique]
George Baum présente jazz
parade retransmission différé des
concerts dominicau donné au théâtre
Édouard sous le patronage du H Club de
Paris
vous entendrez aujourd'hui pour la
rentrée de Bill à Paris une groupant
autour du musicien noir Michel de Maier
Bernard prise de son Marc TR
collaboration technique
rogeristant de
productioner
Bernard P Jean bouchetti Roger parabochi
et Bill
[Applaudissements]
Colman leses musiciens commencont par
vous
interpréter
G qui pourrait se traduire en
l'occurrence par quand vous êtes revenu
[Musique]
les premières mesures jou par B à son
retour en
[Musique]
Europe après 10 ans d'absence retrouve
sur la scène du
théâre il est entouré pour
interéter qui suès les plus consid
par
Bernich
maanab etbraphone
[Musique]
godali
vous l'avez reconnu au piano c'est
naturellement Bernard
[Musique]
FF c'estour c'est auutour de Michel
devbet
[Musique]
les fanatiques de jazz ont apporté les
appareils photos il garnissent le
premier rang du terratre et mitraill B
pendant qu'il joue
[Musique]
et Paris enthousiaste salue le retour de
Colman
[Musique]
au vibrapone
géodalie
[Musique]
et Maurice mier attaque à la
clarinette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'ambiance le morceau d'ouverture est à
son paroxisme tous les musiciens
français sont très joyeux de jouir avec
leur grand aîné leur joie se lit sur
leur
visage
[Musique]
h
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hello B
hell Bill Colman le fameux trompette
noir que les Parisiens n'ont pas eu la
joie d'applaudir depuis 1938 et près de
nous il débarque à peine de l'avion qui
vient de l'amener à or et sa première
apparition à Paris avant même
l'ouverture de ce cercle des enfants des
do
il doit présider c'est un Jaz parade qu'
l' réservé nous sommes au thâre et la
prière question que je
poserai c'est celleci plus classique
heureux B d'être à Paris je suis
cont puisque et tout le monde s'en réjou
puisque cette apparition c'est l'éserv
pvezv nous dire pvezv dire aitesiste à
New York é
ja queon trouve au thére organisé par le
club de
parisistetatsis éival de concerts je
pense qu'il fait allusion
ici
na pu nous rejoindre qu'au tout dernier
moment et ce matin encore nousattendions
avec beaucoup d'impatience c'est en
effet
queateten auats-unis jusqu la dernière
minutez sont les orchestres avec lesqu
vousz l'ion de jouer rment aux
[Musique]
États-Unis
bien nous allonsois demander auparavant
à
Charles de nous préciser en quelques
mots la situation de B dans la musique
de une tche difficile résumer en
quelques
instants la réputation des grand Tromp
de la génération qui a suivi celle
de classe ENF c'est une question de cou
bien entendu ile par des musiciens comme
Jones auditeurs vont pouvoir à leur tour
en
juger et maintenant près de Bill Colman
et nous sommes un peu étonné de la
rencontrer là voici edit de Berg edit de
Berg que vous avez tous beaucoup aimé
dans l'aigle à deux têtes et don vous
savez tous qu'elle son nomme car c'est
déjà une grande vedette Sylvia Montfort
Sylvia Montfort s'est échappé aux
représentations du théâtre Saint-George
où elle joue actuellement une pièce
adaptée de l'américain par son mari
Maurice Clavel et elle est venue au
concert c'est donc je présume silv
Monfort que vous aimez la musique de Jaz
j'aime le jazz j'aime surtout les Blues
je reste très attaché au premers Blu qui
étaent vraiment à cette époque les
improvisations collectives alors qu'on
les enregistr sans même qu'il le sache
dans des auberges dans les bourges de la
Nouvelle Orléan mais je ne suis pas
insensible non plus à l'évolution du
jazz et le B qui laisse une ouverture
sur l'avenir musical du jazz très grande
toujoursussi mais de manière très
différente cette largeur d'esprit ne
nous étonne pas de vous de vous tout le
monde sait que vous êtes non seulement
une comédienne apprécié mais une
romancière une romancière sans doute
bientô en vogue après ce retour en
arrière nous allons vous voulez bien
regarder un peu dans l'avenir sont sy
mon projs immédiat jeour la Prin
stie
sec je je jusqu bien nous sou de jouer
encore trèstemp la pièce vousmême et vos
camaradesir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
now like to play you little
SL
[Musique]
solpiras
solpirpiraspppp săpire
săpire săpire
[Musique]
să
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
săpir
săp săp
pp salpir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salpiririr
ainsi s'achève ce concert de Jaz parade
qui marque la rentrée à Paris de Bill
Colman c'est un triomphe vous l'entendez
et Bill Colman donnera un second concert
dimanche prochain avec Hubert rostin
Bernard Jean-Claude forenb ici George Ba
qui vous dit amateur de jazz à mercredi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez entendu jazz parade au théâtre
Édouard 7 une production de George
[Musique]
Baum cette émission vous a fait entendre
la GEM session donnée sous le patronage
du Hot Club de Paris pour la rentrée du
trompette américain
entour mich maceier
bernardog paraboch et Jean
bchet prise de son Marcel Trolet
collaboration technique Roger nav
assistant de production Robert
[Musique]
ch